My name is Robinson Crusoe, and I was born in 1632 in the city of York.
My father gave me a good education and wanted me to be a lawyer.
I didn't want to be a lawyer. I wanted to be a sailor and go to sea.
My father was very angry with me.
He asked me why I wanted to leave his house,...
...where I would have an easy and comfortable life.
I argued with my parents for another year.
Then I went to Hull with a friend who was going to London on a ship.
He invited me to go with him and I agreed.
I did not ask my parents. I did not even tell them. I just went.
I made a will, and soon we were ready to sail.
The ship had sixteen men.
We had good weather at first and sailed north along the coast of Brazil.
However, as soon as we left the coast and headed toward Africa, there was a terrible storm.
The wind blew the waves very high, but it also blew us toward the shore.
We were certain that the big waves would smash the boat on the shore.
Suddenly, an even larger wave turned the boat upside down, and we all fell into the wild sea.